sans surprise la russie continue
d'afficher son soutien à son voisin sur
ce dossier le kremlin avait fait savoir
hier qu'il n'y avait pas de raison de ne
pas croire les explications des
dirigeants biélorusses
alors que le premier ministre grec a
déclaré cet après midi qu'il n'existait
aucune preuve de la présence d'agents du
kgb dans l'avion le ministre des
affaires étrangères russe a quant à lui
appelé à ce que l'on cesse de diaboliser
la biélorusse oui nous insistons sur la
nécessité de cesser de diaboliser ceux
qui ne plaisent pas à l'occident
vigneronne les premières minutes après
cet incident les autorités biélorusses
se sont clairement déclarés disposés à
être transparent est devenu que pas
mener une enquête ouverte à accueillir
des experts en la matière et fournir
l'ensemble des renseignements et des
matériaux nécessaires
ils ont déjà diffusé une partie de ces
renseignements de manière unilatérale
mais le comportement de nos collègues
occidentaux surtout celui des pays
baltes est indécent du point de vue de
la diplomatie pour moi tu es jusqu'au
mur comme du public
en effet le chef de la diplomatie
européenne compte faire payer le prix
fort alexandre loukachenko dans cette
affaire josette borel a évoqué des
pistes de sanction des sanctions
économiques en particulier dans les
domaines du gaz et de la potasse afin de
frapper la ville russie au portefeuille
mais minsk eux peut compter sur la
solidarité de moscow dernier exemple
concret en date la russie qui vient de
faire savoir qu'elle cesserait de
délivrer des permis d'arriver pour les
vols en direction de la russie qui
contournerait le territoire biélorusse
ça a été le cas cet après midi encore
d'un vol qui devait assurer la liaison
entre vienne et moscou c'est donc dans
ce contexte que vladimir poutine va
recevoir demain son homologue biélorusse
à sotchi dans le sud de la russie